en plus quand même c'est explosif
politiquement ce genre d'image parce que
il ya une partie des français on l'a vu
dans le passé qu'ils sont extrêmement
hostile à ce genre de manifestation bien
sûr et cette affaire et a pris de
l'ampleur à partir du moment où les élus
de la ville de clichés les élus
régionaux d'île de france ont décidé de
ne de porter ce débat là sur le terrain
politique en organisant une
contre-manifestation martinez avec leurs
écharpes voile alors on l'a vu ici même
vendredi dernier et ça a donné
d'ailleurs lieu un certain nombre de
commentaires un petit peu surprenant où
on lisait que c'était les élus qui
perturbait une prière de rue
l'association musulmane qui organisait
ces prières a porté plainte contre la
moitié doit faire contre la mairie alors
que là pour le coup je n'investis a bien
résumé la situation en l'occurrence
c'est vrai que leur local a été fermé
mais qu'il ya eu une autre proposition
utiliser la prière de rue comme chantage
c'est vraiment jouer avec le feu dans
une situation aujourd'hui qui est
politiquement très tendu